Ramzi solutions Peter and Margaret are
with us hey guys welcome welcome were
you from Knoxville oh very fun welcome
to Nashville and here to do your
debt-free scream huh yes sir I love it
how much have you guys paid off about a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars in
five years more recently about forty
thousand dollars in the last six months
when we decided to get real gizelle
intense ah okay and your range of income
during that five years 90 to 140 okay
very cool what do you guys do for a
living I'm a mining engineer and I do
workers compensation case management
from home very cool good for you gosh
very good so what kind of debt was the
one thirty Oh primarily student loans on
my behalf about seventy five thousand
and then I got a big dumb truck that was
about thirty-five a big dumb truck Oh
big big dumb another car and you know
here and there not not any credit card
debt luckily I am second-generation
financial piece my parents always sold
it from a young age absolutely so how
old are you I am 28 so where were they
how did they get connected with us all
those years ago that's initially from a
church on the church and then they
actually even taught it at their
employer later on I mean this was a long
time ago yeah I'm thinking which church
yeah well I started at West Hills
Baptist and we've took it at first
Farragut United Methodist Church taxable
all right cuz yeah I remember doing
stuff at West Hills 100 years ago that's
what I was thinking okay fine
very cool for you guys so second
generation you knew what to do you guys
I'm gonna guess and say you may got
married about five years ago correct yes
sir so you kind of started but then tell
me the story what happened six months
ago and why did you just kind of start
five years ago well she had been on me
for a little while about the truck and
one Saturday I was sitting on the couch
staring out the window and all I could
think was man that truck is just sitting
there not doing me any good so later
that week we drove to Carmack's and got
rid of it oh and oh yeah that sold the
motorcycle yep got rid of the toys and
within the six months we were able to
you have the final death knell okay so
you had already paid off 90,000 yes all
right but you just kind of stuck right
we had been making the right choices
thanks to you and no how you know we had
been making many right choices but we
definitely by no means we're gazelle
intense not sure we were saving
appropriately for retirement we were
making payments to student loans we
didn't have credit card debt you are
saving appropriately for retirement if
you were saving for retirement at all as
you were supposed to be just working on
the debt right so that was a big key for
us was figuring out that we're not
special okay so you were doing modified
Dave translation crap oh okay so when
did you go through Financial Peace
University we went through it as part of
our premarital counseling as well yeah
so in 2011 okay so when we went through
it together as a couple so you just got
like a c-plus in the class and had to
come back and retake and got your a
d-minus
okay Wow well hey good news is you
didn't do more damage you just didn't
make as much progress correct exactly as
you should have and you felt stuck and
so you I'm interested though peers
because that's an interesting
conversation that happens in our brains
and since I've worked with people for 30
years on transforming their lives what
happens in me too you know what happens
inside my brain what happens inside your
brain when you're sitting on the couch
that day and all of a sudden it's like
I'm over this what do you think happened
there I just figured it was it was time
to move forward yeah we had it it got to
a point where we wanted to make more
money we had a lot of what we called
side hustles we were hosting on Airbnb
we drove uber I mean we were wanting to
make money to pay off this debt but we
were still spending money we were making
money paying off debt but still spending
money and still running the retirement
right yes or no okay so I think that it
just got to the point six months ago
where we were just I was like we're
never going to pay it off unless we pay
it off yeah here we are and then all of
a sudden you just step on it and go okay
trucks gone we're getting serious let's
finish this game yeah okay do you have
any idea what flipped the switch well I
mean the the switch was definitely
already on with me the whole time if he
had asked about financial goals
to be debt free to be debt free to be
debt free to be debt free and I think
finally it just took a while to
internalize it yeah for me it was
driving uber during one of those primary
UT football games last fall when I
worked all weekend and thriving uber at
a football game yes sir and I thought
that's just not worth it I'll just sell
the truck and get rid of it I'm thinking
I don't want some of these people in my
truck we had people in our cars people
in our homes with Airbnb we had we've
had people from all over the world stay
with us and anything to make a little
bit of extra money to pay off that debt
it's only wonderful on small doses yeah
yeah Wow good for you guys okay I get it
you got sick and tired of being sick and
tired I'm just sorry okay that's
interesting well I'm proud of y'all
congratulations you're heroes well thank
you to control your life I didn't pay
any of it it wasn't me driving over I'll
tell you well way to go you guys very
very very well done all right
so what was your best month ever with
uber what's the most you made I think we
drove during an Alabama UT football game
and made about 1,200 bucks working ten
hours on a Saturday oh really one day
yes sir oh wow yeah okay
so they hit a premium on that day oh
very much so yeah when there's more
people at inter surge pricing and it
really gets it gets exponentially more
expensive the fairs do okay so you want
to drive on those days right primarily
what we did was drive on those days you
couldn't get rid of the Alabama fans
soon enough to the county line all right
all right Peter and Margaret Knoxville
Tennessee go Vols a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars paid off in five years
but 40 of it in the last six months
making ninety to 140 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream one two three
- very well done hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
economy